what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with another invincible video
the video itself is quite literally
invincible it's indestructible because
it exists in the digital space so here's
the thing this initially opens up
with omnipotence this guy sucks all
right so if you guys remember in
invincible issue number 27 this guy
tried to like conquer the world but was
basically destroyed like his world was
dying so he was trying to absorb the
energies of earth and yada yada so
basically he shows back up again and for
the most part i mean it's cool right he
takes out like the guardians of the
globe and all that kind of stuff and
that's interesting for what it is it
doesn't really matter instead you end up
having mark and dinosaurs who show up
here right now here's the funny thing
here dinosaurs is nothing if not just
exceedingly resilient insofar as what he
believes right that mark's kind of
pissed off over the fact that dinosaurs
didn't tell him earlier that his friends
had basically been defeated by
omnipotence and the response of
dinosaurs is yeah but like the
irrigation channels that you were
digging were way more important in this
grand scheme of things then like your
friends fighting some enemy out there
right so i only alerted you when it was
clear that we'd actually be needed now
when they show up here they kind of get
pummeled a little bit and then dinosaurs
basically bites the head off of
omnipotence and that's the end of him
right that's basically the end of that
guy right so again he sucks like he's
just he's not interesting at all like
literally he explodes right which is
kind of cool right all that energy just
sort of just explodes outward and that's
basically it but this is when things
begin to get interesting because once
the other members of the guardians of
the globe begin to wake up remember mark
and dinosaurs are fugitives in the eyes
of the law right that dinosaurs actions
led to the total destruction of las
vegas under the idea that las vegas
housing a whole bunch of casinos and
stuff like that was a colossal waste
that because of its location it was
actually an ideal location for a huge
solar array and that using that solar
array could power just a huge portion of
the united states and so following all
these explosions and the destruction of
las vegas it actually turned the area to
glass which led to the formation of
solar panels that actually had the added
benefit that not only would the sun
shine down directly on the panels that
it would also hit the glass and then
reflect and shine on the backside of the
panels so humanity was actually able to
double the energy they would get from
solar panels so sure lots of people died
but something much better came out of
their deaths and so in response to this
mark had actually freed dinosaurs under
the idea that his ideas are good but the
way he goes about them are a problem and
so for the most part mark's basically
been m.i.a and so he hasn't seen eve for
quite some time i want to be honest with
you guys eve is quite possibly the most
patient woman to ever exist in the
history of the world like literally her
man has left earth for months at a time
which sent her into a depression she
ended up having an abortion because she
simply just couldn't handle everything
that was going on he's a fugitive from
the law
he's faced death i don't know how many
times and she still stays by his side if
ever there were a woman to marry mark
this is probably it you'll probably
never do any better than this at least
not in terms of a woman with patience
and so because of all that there's this
huge conversation that happens between
the two right eve was never on board
with the idea of mark basically taking
off becoming a vigilante a fugitive
working alongside dinosaurs because of
what had happened in las vegas but mark
creates a really really cool counter
argument here right he says the
ideologies the the practicality of the
things that dinosaurs believes they're
good things right there are huge
sections of the world that are being
wasted on things that don't matter right
we have kind of allowed that to go on
because you know despite what we say and
do we don't really want things to change
and if we do want things to change we
want them to change without having to
actually put any effort in right the
greatest reward for the least amount of
work and so with this in mind mark's
like the way he does things sure
destroying las vegas is a problem you
get no argument from me there right but
the ideologies he have they work and so
mark's whole position here operating
alongside dinosaurs is actually to
basically be a kind of conscience in the
sense that when dinosaurs is like okay
so we should eradicate france so we can
we can turn the catacombs into like
something that can benefit the whole of
humanity then like the responsible mark
is no dinosaurus we should not eradicate
france but we can work with the french
military or the french government to do
something with the catacombs but we
shouldn't eradicate the whole of france
right i mean there's a better way to do
this right it's just that kind of a
thing right that kind of a system and so
in the middle of all this cecil shows up
of course as you would basically expect
now the funny thing here is that cecil
didn't bring an entire army and he even
says that right like i didn't bring the
guardians of the globe i didn't bring
like a giant squadron with me which i
could have done if my goal was to
apprehend you instead i just basically
want to talk to you and that's one of
the funny things here is that when you
look at cecil as a character sure he
does some pretty shady stuff but in his
mind it's all part of the greater good
now i would say him showing up here to
mark is really him still trying to
maintain some aspect of that kind of
mentor role where he's like look man i
get where you're coming from but here's
the problem you sound so naive right
this idea that you can take someone like
dinosaurs who had this plan to to wipe
out the total the totality of las vegas
right all those people died the fact
that you can control this guy right the
sky dinosaurs who basically wiped out
the entirety of las vegas and those
people were evacuated by by just an inch
from total destruction you believe that
you can contain and control this guy
mark your naive now that's the other
part of cecil and it's one of the
reasons why and there's really
justification here for mark not
necessarily trusting cecil in this way
the reason being because one of the
things that ceci will do despite the
fact that he seems to be operating under
what he believes to be the right thing
to do it's one of those instances where
he would do some shady stuff he would
basically gaslight mark right no no no
no it's not you know and basically mess
with his head and screw with him and
then trick him into believing that
cecil's the only one who can basically
contain a dinosaurs and then he would
use dinosaurs for his own ants which was
most likely what they were going to do
in the first place of course as they
kept them contained they kept the
dinosaurs personality at bay but then
once they figured out what it was they
wanted to do or they approached
dinosaurs so they had something to offer
that would get dinosaurs to work with
them then they would have gone forward
from there and so that lack of trust is
a little bit justified as far as mark
goes now of course in the middle of this
conversation he's basically told that
alan the alien is showing up on earth
and so of course mark takes off to meet
alan the alien now here's the funny
thing about this right what happens here
is exactly what happened in the last
video right where basically mark stands
against what it is that alan the alien
wants to do where he basically tells him
look i've devised a plan where i'm going
to release the scourge virus on earth
there is a chance mark it could destroy
the entirety of your race but we know
it'll destroy all the viltrumites so at
the end of the day the death of your of
everybody on your world is a small price
to pay to save the universe here's a
funny thing about this right this is one
of those instances where mark like you
like me like many of us we're selective
on on the nature of our morality we pick
and choose what we want to be moral
about and how far we let that morality
go here's what i mean by this what alan
the alien is doing here what he's
proposing is no different than what
dinosaurs is proposing right dinosaurus
argues that like there are times when
because of the goal and the nature of
things they want to achieve the needs of
the many outweigh the needs of the few
so if all those people in las vegas had
died it'd be a small price to pay sure i
mean i guess it sucks but to like save
the world or to like protect the world
that's just the way that it goes right
and while mark kind of curtails that too
a little bit it's also mark being
basically hypocritical here because how
many fights has mark engaged in in
populated places where buildings were
destroyed buildings collapsed on people
where people were killed and it was
collateral damage yet mark continued to
operate as a superhero in that capacity
knowing that kind of thing would take
place that he didn't really try to lead
people away he would just end up in a
conflict there and so the lack of desire
to lead people away from populated areas
during fights right to move the villains
elsewhere on the other side of the
equation is saying yes i know people are
going to die here i don't care and so
that basically leads to people being
killed as collateral damage but then
suddenly when alan the alien comes along
and says okay mark so your morality
right your utilitarian approach that the
needs of the many outweigh the needs of
the few that this is a localized
situation right it's how you operate
here on earth i'm looking at it on a
grander scale and it could lead to the
destruction of your entire race then
suddenly it becomes a problem it's not a
problem until mark arbitrarily decides
that it is a problem and that's kind of
how we as humans function when it comes
to morality right we pick and choose
what's important we pick and choose what
is or is not the right thing to do and
in wax and wanes in this instance alan
the alien is saying look the whole of
the universe is facing a threat by the
continued existence of the viltrumite
race you're hoping that you can reform
them that you can turn them into good
people but there's no guarantee that's
going to happen and because of the fact
that they represent a clear and present
danger to the universe they have to die
and because you allowed them to merge
with your planet you brought this on
yourself it's harboring a fugitive who
won't leave your house that person's
gotta go looks like you gotta go with
them and this is one of those things
where mark and and really his family
right so like mark nolan all those guys
had to consider this as some kind of a
possibility there's no conceivable way
that this grand plan was constructed
without acknowledging the possibility
someone will come looking for them and
someone will try to destroy them and
when that happens they may destroy us at
the same time it's just kind of a
willful ignorance with that part of the
equation and so much like you would
expect from nolan marx stands in his way
and it's like no that's not going to
happen right like i'm not going to let
you release the scourge virus on our
world and potentially destroy the whole
of humanity right i would rather that
the villager might potentially be you
know go back to their role of being a
race that would try to conquer the
universe then let seven billion people
die it's one of those kind of backwards
morality clauses right it's one of those
backwards moral concepts where it's like
the needs of the few outweigh the needs
of the many it doesn't really make any
sense when you start looking at it that
way right when you strip away the
emotional component and you look at it
from a logical perspective it makes no
absolute sense i mean sure it sucks the
seven billion people on earth will die
that's a small price to pay sorry about
your luck mark i mean that's just the
way it goes right how many countless
people out there die in wars and
conflicts that you never think about
right if you're arguing this from like
the value of life that value must not
matter too much because you don't really
give a second thought to anybody else
out there that dies from any number of
conflicts so again arbitrarily creating
moral standards to fit whatever desire
we want to see fulfilled and so this
basically leads to a fight breaking out
between the two now again alan the alien
is pretty far above mark mark's not on
the same level as alan alien and he gets
absolutely pummeled right i mean he gets
absolutely trashed and it's one of these
things where like the whole time that
it's going on alan's like you're wasting
time right now mark's hole stance is
like the people on this world like on
this planet you know all those
individuals they're innocent people they
don't deserve to die and it's not as
though alan the alien is condemning them
because he's vindictive mark and his
family put them in the crosshairs they
put them there they put them in that
position they had humanity intermingle
with the viltromite race knowing
something like this could happen at a
future point in time if they didn't want
that to happen they shouldn't have done
this in the first place right it's
creating their own problem and then
complaining about the consequence of
that problem and so ultimately in this
huge conflict this huge battle that goes
on between the two the question that
alan the alien asks is nolan could not
stop me your father could not defeat me
mark what chance do you think you have
and then boom out of nowhere comes
freddie mercury thrag himself who says
he has me with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
thank you guys for watching and i will
catch you all later
peace